OK, ready?
Brian: Yep.
Oh, my God.
Have it drop right in.
Ah!
Oh!
Boom!
Suck it, Kinsey.
Narrator: We visited Brian Baumgartner
and Angela Kinsey on
set, and they showed us
their best beer-pong techniques.
They'll cover how to score points,
how to prevent your opponent from scoring,
and how to be the life of the party.
This is a game called beer pong.
Right? Brian: Yeah.
OK.
Brian: Go ahead.
I'm a little excited.
I've never played before.
Brian: Oooh.
Angela: Yay!
Narrator: First up,
Angela and Brian show us
how to get the perfect
arc for the basic shot.
First is the arc shot.
You wanna arc it in.
Get it? Arc shot.
OK, so my strategy is gonna be
to
look at the cup.
OK, ready?
Ah!
I got it in!
I did it!
I need a little victory dance
though because I made it.
So here's my victory...
It's very simple, all you have to do
is think of wanting to
throw this at your head
and have it drop right in.
Angela: Oh!
Brian: Boom!
Suck it, Kinsey!
Angela: How stoked are
you that you made that?
You are so pumped right now.
Narrator: Next, the
two-pointer bounce shot.
Bounce shot is a little trickier
because Kinsey could swat it away.
Oh, I can?
Yeah, you could swat away.
Oh, this is fun.
But if it's in the air, you can't swat it.
I have to swat it after the bounce?
Brian: After the bounce. Angela: OK.
So if I bounce it, then you could swat it.
OK.
But if I throw it, then you can't.
Ohhh!
Narrator: If your team sinks both shots...
Balls back, balls back, balls back!
Narrator: In the case of
a ball that bounces back
without hitting the floor,
the player can attempt a trick shot.
I'm now going to try
to make my game harder.
I'm going to do a trick shot.
Brian: All right. Angela:
Which means I'm gonna go
behind my back.
Even though the table is really
high for a short person.
Brian: Let's go.
So I'm making it doubly hard
because technically I think
the table should be lower.
Just gonna say that.
OK, ready, here I go.
That was awful.
Trick shot behind the back and...f---.
I want you to just take a breath.
OK, oh, and try it again?
Try it again.
Don't be hard on yourself. You got this.
Brian: Gotta go up. Angela: Go up, yeah.
All right, ready?
Yeah.
Oh, so close!
Ah!
One more.
Get there!
Yaaaaay!
Yeah!
That's an alley-oop.
Angela: Sometimes you need an assist.
Brian: That's an alley-oop.
Angela: Sometimes.
Narrator: As you start to sink some shots
and your cups get further
and further apart...
Restack!
What's that mean?
Yeah, I knew that you wouldn't know.
Narrator: Or per official
terminology, the rerack.
Oh, rerack.
Oh, you said it wrong!
Doesn't count.
Doesn't count!
Brian: I don't care.
Angela: You said restack.
I don't care.
Narrator: Each team gets
one rerack per game.
Brian and Angela opted for a honeycomb.
Restack!
Brian: Yeah, there you go.
Angela: Oh, I'm tickled, Brian.
This is cracking me up.
OK, you ready?
Here we go.
You got it. You got it.
No, you don't.
You got it.
OK, you got it.
Narrator: Now that Brian and
Angela have covered shooting,
it's time to discuss defensive strategies.
Windmill, windmill.
Ow!
Distraction!
Ah!
Ninja reflexes!
I don't need to distract her, look.
Ricocheted.
No, that's not.
It ricocheted off you.
No, that doesn't count.
That doesn't.
Ow!
Narrator: Now, they'll
put it all together.
Oh no.
Oh, good, good.
So now this is removed, and I drink this.
Brian: Oh, my God.
Angela: Oh, my God, this is so much fun.
But, you know, be responsible.
Yay!
Oooh nice!
One more.
Angela: You have to drink.
Oh, yeah.
Angela: Oh, nope.
Oh, nope.
Stop mocking me in that way.
Angela: Yay!
Brian: Yeah!